so questions coming in from Instagram as
well if you want to call in with a
question up from a teenager by a
teenager about a teenager this is your
time the phone numbers triple eight
eight two five five two two four two two
five um I don't know who four is going
to go to anyway Instagram question how
do I know Anthony that I'm picking the
right path for my future is my dream
career going to end up making me
successful in life or cause me to
struggle mm that's a good question
I would definitely say make sure that
your dream career is matching your
passion because if your passion is not
matching your career then I don't
believe in the future you will be
struggling because if you're not
passionate about what you're doing then
you're going to eventually not like it
down the road like I'm very passionate
about talking to you reaching the young
people and really making sure they
understand and make wise decisions with
their money with their finances and with
their choices so that's my passion so
that's why I'm here and I love it
I could do this for free but if you're
gonna arrange that no sir no sir no sir
no later sir - sir but I mean that would
be my first suggestion is make sure that
you know your career is what you're
really passionate about it cuz sometimes
when I was young I wanted to be a lawyer
but I wasn't passionate about it I just
knew they made a lot of money but I
really wasn't passionate about that you
were an awful lawyer I really would have
I really I really and I would not be
making good money so I'm living where
I'm at so Simone I would agree with him
on that I would also tell you that you
would you know look at the path like he
said you look at the the what do most
people that do that thing you're
thinking about what kind of money do
they make and is the path going to do
that and is it going to make you
successful in life or cause you to
struggle let me just tell you you're not
going to be successful unless you
struggle yeah struggle you can just
about a hundred percent count on
absolutely and the the gleaming mountain
of success is not really a gleaming
mountain it's more like a pile of
garbage that you're standing on it's all
the crap you went through to get there
absolutely you just standing on it still
laying under it that's the only
difference
so it's not
is there's really not a yellow brick
road and you and the Cowardly Lion
really aren't going to skip to see Oz
it's going to be more of a cloth scrap
and fight and and bust your way into it
regardless of your career and regardless
of your passion so pick something you're
passionate about pick something that has
a good track record in the marketplace
of actually making a living and then
count on a struggle and the struggle is
fun though
yes and it's part of this part of the
embrace it man step into it
alright Kiara is with us in Atlanta
Georgia hi Kiera how are you hi Anthony
hey Kara how are you your question for
Anthony my question is I played two
years old and I'm currently in a
master's program and I'll graduate in
July with about 18,000 and student loan
debt right now from the money that I
have a budget it's probably not the best
budget but I have a budget and I save a
lot of my money but at the rate that I'm
saving I only have saved about maybe
7,500 by the time I graduate so I'm
really unsure I said what my next step
should be just as far as paying off my
student loan debt and setting yes to not
be in debt going to my real adult life
what's your master's in marriage and
Family Therapy good for you you got your
job lined up coming out yes I have an
internship now and hopefully that turns
into a job it looks promising though
cool what kind of pain I'm sorry much
will you be making if you got the jump
entering level is about 3035 thousand
and then as I get more some
certifications I can stand to make on 70
or 80 thousand but you know that comes
over Arian yeah but if you stop if you
step out what we're saying is you're
making thirty five thousand you get
seventy five hundred a bank you got
eighteen thousand dollar student loan
debt that's that's kind of our picture
upon graduation right yeah okay
Anthony well you know it's a good
question and congrats on getting there
the first thing that I seek here are
though is you have a budget so I'm
definitely want to say get that budget
solid because you said it's a kind of
iffy budget so I really want to get your
your plans and your money on paper and
get it solid then the next one for me is
when I'm looking at $18,000 in student
loans you're going to have when you
graduate but then you also already have
$7,500 in the savings account
I would I would take about 6500 of that
out and put it towards your debt keep
$1,000 for your emergency fund cadets we
teach for baby step number one and then
get rid of all that debt so when you
graduate and you go into your field
you're going into it with as much less
debt as you possibly can so that would
be my suggestion because I want you to
get out there and get ahead of the game
and not get out there and get this great
job now you're looking back at the past
so that would be my first thing what's
what you think of Dave I agree I think
you're right on target that's exactly
what I would do and exactly tighten up
the budget and then just make it your
first goal with the tight budget to
clean up whatever student loans debt
that is left so that you can move on the
good news is that you're used to living
like a college student absolutely and if
you keep living like a college student
while you start making grown-up money
you can you can you can trash that
student loan debt pretty quick you can
knock it out and so and the other good
the best news of the whole thing is
you're smart enough to even ask the
question yeah and so congratulations on
finishing up your master's that's a
great accomplishment but also you know
you're asking the question you're
looking out here going what have I got
to do to win so I want you to hold on
I'm going to send you a copy the book
the Total Money Makeover as my
graduation gift to you and it'll show
you exactly what to do step by step you
know it's so much there is no arm
there's no one in any situation coming
out of college or coming out of high
school that can't and enter into a
winning process but 98% of is that is
them just knowing they need to just she
made that choice to even make that phone
call that's huge yeah especially at 22
Day for me now I take my hats off to her
that is she's gonna go far in life
because she asked that one question and
now she's alone she just applies what we
just gave her and do some more stuff man
she's gonna be amazing
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
out so you have to break the cycle you
have to flip this thing on its head and
make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind